I am so excited because we get to do
what I love to do the most today we are
on our way to San Diego by way of Papa's
awesome truck with the cedar here we
don't have a little guy in the front
today he's in the back right now
enjoying what are you eating dude
okay I I was gonna reveal me a later
dude what are you eating
the yummiest thing in the whole wide
world
McFlurry and of course we have our Mia
with us we don't leave home without her
remember that what is it look
what what's the credit card company you
don't want to leave home without it
anyway it doesn't matter Visa I might be
even if before my time okay you're only
a year on younger oh there's a lot of
kid Years anyway so yeah
um uh yeah road trip is my favorite just
because we just do so much in a day that
I at least I don't know if you ever feel
this way but I feel slightly guilty when
I'm not moving
like Adventures
what's that
[Music]
yeah well how do you what do you think
about it because I love road trips I
don't know what you think dude
it's interesting you like them or you
don't like them it thinks it's
interesting you think it's interesting
oh okay
uh no oh yeah so do you feel guilty when
you're not being productive in doing
stuff yeah you know how often I sit on
the couch a week do you have you noticed
never I've never seen you I literally
sit on the couch less than five minutes
a week that's how like active I am in my
life so like when I get to sit on those
the really cool velvet chairs that you
picked out yeah like it is rare when I
don't even notice it like I don't even
realize how rare it is but when you do
sit there I go oh this is nice but I
think it's because I never see it but
when I sit there I feel like I'm at like
the Four Seasons like I'm like it's like
a treat so when I sit there I go oh it
actually feels really good because I'm
like I get to be in my own living room
but I'm in my own living room literally
less than five minutes a week it's not
crazy do you think it's because you have
ADHD
have so much to do that like
that like the put the car in park for a
second okay well I get to sit on the
couch a little bit more than you do the
whole thing the whole thing how do you
do that that's interesting wasn't he
saying he was getting full with apples
so I told him he needed to finish his
apples to finish the good stuff before
he gets the ice cream and then he only
ate like half of the apples Papa I'm
getting four of them oh I felt bad like
he had such a good day today so I wanted
to keep that high note honest I'm like
okay you know what you don't have to
finish the apples and then it's the big
old thing look how big that McFlurry is
hey look at that face look at that face
how did you finish that whole thing you
big munchkins
here but you said you were full how did
you finish how did you fit that whole
thing in your little tummy because it is
I'll come you couldn't squishes them out
yeah how come you're gonna squish in the
last two apples
just like someone I know yeah Mia she's
like hey I didn't do anything
okay so taika has been playing this game
that he created for a few months now and
Taiko what is this game that you always
play with us
say it loudly I can't hear you this car
is huge
an animal has to eat another animal
so how does it work you pick an animal
and then Papa has to try to beat it and
then you have to try to be Papas
oh true okay who's gonna go first
the Apex print well if you started he
knows apex predator excuse me if you
start with the apex predator that's the
top of the food chain there's no way I
can beat that you got to start small
mister
yeah what do you say to that
yeah but then the game ends that's what
Papa's saying I'll start small you ready
a frog
I'm gonna say a cousin
a turtle you think you think a turtle
could beat up a frog eat a frog eat a
eat a frog yeah
I'll see I don't think turtles eat frogs
young man
[Music]
yeah I don't think that works he
probably said it doesn't work so you
gotta try again
a snake
oh that's a good one well I pick I pick
a crocodile oh no
crocodiles eat snakes yeah they do
okay you gotta follow ruthless nature or
whatever no I can't because
[Music]
rhinoceros eats a crocodile
yeah maybe if it was threatening it's
like like it's baby I thought rhinoceros
is our herbivores oh come on are you
serious
he can if he wanted to he could kill it
for sure or step on its head
are we gonna accept rhinoceros
if we want to play in this clown world
with a five-year-old I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go with
a pack of lions a pack of lions
[Music]
oh some lines might be allergic to bees
in a five-year-old's world
I don't think a bee can kill a lion's
allergic because allergic reactions
foreign
[Music]
no he said a bear
no you did it Papa started it Papa said
frog
[Music]
oh
oh I think you won
oh my God
okay well let's hope the other games
don't pop up because the other games get
crazier
I'm just not even gonna spoil it for you
so if he decides he wants to share it I
will record it if not you'll never know
right so it's a rest stop time
specifically because it's two which
means taika needs to take his nap
because if you've been following Along
on taika's health Journey we've figured
that the lack of sleep or when he's
tired that will trigger a seizure so so
far we've been almost six months uh
seizure free or he's been almost six
months seizure free uh and it's been so
good to the point that he is now taking
one medication because we've been
successful on weaning him off of the
other medication he was taken off
because he hasn't had seizures so we
want to maintain that so it whatever
cost we're gonna make sure he gets his
sleep so I brought a sheet I already
cleaned where Mia was
I took off all the fur put the sheet
just to be extra safe because she puts
her little butthole on that seat and my
son is not gonna sleep in that so MIA
will be on the floor here and there's
like a ton of space like let me just
show you this is a little car seat
that's what he sits on and look at all
that room still here so MIA will be here
right next to the AC Tiger's gonna take
a nap he's probably gonna stay for like
two hours which is gonna be so sick
um and yeah we're ready to go
what the hell where'd they go
oh there you are all right it's ready
monks
whoa
ready to take a nap
they're pythons yeah I counted them and
it was one feet yeah oh that looks
luxurious yeah keep your shoes on the
bottom right there take them off there
so you don't step on the nice clean
stuff
man you're gonna sleep so good okay come
on come on because that Mia's gonna get
in it
yeah
you got to put your head
on this yes come on
um
[Music]
there it is
yeah oh yeah come on Mia and you see
yeah fits perfectly don't let her get on
top you know the drill
oh no good night
can I take a nap with you monkey yes
[Music]
you're going to sleep okay
good night
look at all dead
girl
you have all that space over there
how are you gonna lay down
just woke up from an almost two hour nap
and now Mia oh it was like an hour and
like 32 minutes Taiga yeah now Mia has
her seat back we haven't stopped we're
still we're about two hours away from
our destination
um taika can I tell you something yeah
you were really smart
you know why
because when we were home and packing
he was like hey Mom can I pack my own
snack bag and I was like dude you don't
have to pack any snacks we always
guessed that before we go on any road
trip and usually attached to a gas
station is those little Convenience
Stores
um so I was like we're just gonna get
snacks like don't worry dude
a little bit longer yeah but you did
what you wanted anyway you packed your
own snacks and I said I'm gonna wait
because I'm gonna buy it and you know
what happened
we didn't even get we didn't go to a gas
station that had snacks so I didn't get
any snacks Tyga has all the snacks
don't be fooled it's not a toy it's a
what
a lollipop Mia got fooled
she's ashamed of herself
no this is not when she eats she eats in
the morning and at night
we're about an hour away from our
destination not at this point
um it's been so CUNY in the car right
now because Papa's been singing to a lot
of live music he has his phone who are
you listening to right now so this is
gonna be Baby Come Back featuring
brother Stone and the get down damn it I
can't
right there yeah so you're watching them
live and you're singing your little
heart out
I've been really into Fae fantasy smut
um oh yeah maybe some spicy reading I
just got I just wrapped up
um a court of thorn and Roses series I
have never read so much in my life so
quickly I finished the series in like
under two months like it was gnarly it's
like five different books anyway so I
just started I'm going backwards I'm now
I'm reading the um I think it's called
Thorn Throne of Glass or something like
that one of her first series I can't
even remember what it's called I gotta
tell you right now it's called hold on
is it Throne of Glass am I just making
that up
I'm like on chapter 20 of this one now
and I can't even believe I don't know
what it's called
no I'm okay so I read off of Kindle it's
the best I do miss
having an actual piece of paper and like
a book a tangible book but I do not miss
it when I'm reading at night oh Throne
of Glass
I was right I don't miss it
um because at night lights are off I'm
reading in my own little bubble it's fun
okay I got I got on attention here I got
excited to share that I've been like
reading some really fun novels
um the point of showing that was that
I'm doing my thing I have my headphones
in my ears because I'm a do you
have a voice in your head when you read
yeah I mean uh my voice is the narrator
and then I play all the characters yeah
yeah sing so some of them talk like this
yeah I like different voice like that
yeah yeah same
um but because I hear my own voice in my
head as I read
when I hear music or anything else it's
super distracting so I don't do it yeah
it me up yeah so I have to play so
I'm playing like soft classical piano
um and then Tyga's back here on his iPad
and then Mia is back here just chilling
in front of the AC she gets I mean she's
husky blood you know so she gets hot
really fast but I could just ask the
craziest question okay go okay keep in
mind he's a kindergarten he's five he
asked
he says
hey papa out of nowhere three times
three times one
does that equal three plus three plus
three plus zero and I was like
okay this kid has a IQ of seven thousand
that's not what you said insane tell the
truth he said
his math is better than yours that's
that's what I said to his Marcus and I
was like you're not wrong this was five
and a half yeah his luck and he is
starting to understand that three times
three times one is three plus three plus
three plus zero it's awesome his logic's
better than yours ready
hey what
so apparently a good example huh okay
but he didn't say he was a choke you
seems to choke me yeah he said in the
example he wants to do it back to you
he's the one messed up
oh wow the battery's dying whoa all
different batteries dying all the time
here in San Diego
it's like a sleeping Papa's taking a
shower Mia's roaming around we're in our
Airbnb right now just had dinner with
our friends I'm gonna call it a night
thank you guys so much for watching our
little car Vlog see
you gotta buy me a
foreign